Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half
mile before my hands start shaking
does seem like
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
I wasn't either.
This episode is brought to you by
99 designs whether you need a logo,
custom website, APP, book
cover or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process
as easy as possible.
I've used 99 designs for years now.
I've used them for book covers,
some mock ups for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times best seller.
Illustrations of all different
types for the multivolume,
the Tao of Seneca where she can check
out and other graphic design projects for
a long time now and I've
been very impressed with the
quality of their designers
and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it.
You should check out some of my
projects@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash
Tim, I really encourage you to take
a look because you will be impressed.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim nine
nine designs has freelance experts in more
than 90 design categories
in their platform.
Lets you work directly with
one designer that you choose.
If you like their stuff,
which is what I did for the Tao of Seneca,
or you can get concepts from multiple
designers and then pick your favorite.
So whether you're starting a business
or just looking for extra design help,
resources, et cetera. 99 designs
has a solution right now.
You guys,
my listeners can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first design.
To check out your first free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page. You can also find their
samples of projects from you guys,
listeners who've used 99
designs for logos, apps,
even product packaging,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Okay.
Hello my darling little mark.
Why this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show
where it is my job to interview world
class performers from every discipline
imaginable. To tease out the habits,
the patterns, the belief systems,
favorite books, whatever it might be
that you can apply to your own life.
In this episode is going to be
a slightly different format.
You will get to what I just mentioned
and it will be with one of the biggest
surprise hit guests that I've ever had
on the podcast and you wanted me to have
him back on to pick up where we left
off and to ask the rapid fire questions
that are your favorites,
which we didn't get to and that is the
purpose of this recording and he does
deliver. His name is Adam.
So without further ado,
let's get into it.
Our guest today is Adam Robinson.
You
can
find
them
on
twitter@iamadamrobinsonoratrobinsonglobalstrategies.com
Adam has made a lifelong
study of outflanking and
outsmarting the competition.
He is rated chess master and has been
awarded a life master title by the United
States Chess Federation as a teenager.
He was personally mentored by Bobby
Fisher in the 18 months leading up to his
winning the world championship.
And Adam and I talked a lot about this
in our first conversation on the Tim
Ferriss show, what you guys can
check out, but back to the bio.
Then in Adam's first career,
he developed a revolutionary approach to
taking standardized tests as one of the
two original cofounders
of the Princeton Review,
his paradigm breaking or category killing
as they say in publishing test prep
book cracking the system.
The sat is the only test prep book
to have ever become a New York Times
bestseller. After selling his
interest in the prince interview,
Adam turned his attention in the early
nineties to the then emerging field of
artificial intelligence developing a
program that could analyze texts and
provide humanlike commentary.
He was later invited to join a well
known quant fund to develop statistical
trading models and since he's established
himself as an independent global macro
advisor to the chief investment officers
of a select group of the world's most
successful hedge funds and ultra
high net worth family offices.
If you could have a gigantic billboard
anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say and why?
Well, first Tim, thanks
for having me back.
It's always a great joy and
a privilege and a pleasure.
I'll leave aside the danger of having a
text heavy billboard that would distract
passing drivers. Instead, I'll
focus on four core quotes.
I live my life by two by others and to
buy me first the two quotes by others.
The first is Rudyard Kipling,
if you did not get what you want,
it's assigned either that you did not
seriously want it or you tried to bargain
over the price. And the second
quote is immediately Earhart's.
The most difficult thing is the decision
to act. The rest is merely tenacity.
Kipling, an Earhart almost
capture the secret to achievement,
but we need to qualify them because
they can lead to obstinate persistence.
Either the goals or methods that aren't
working and because they ignore or
dismiss the emotional
component of achieving goals.
So I'll add two quotes of my own and
the first, and I think this is my
favorite personal quote, if you're
not getting the results you want,
change what you're doing,
you'd think that would be obvious.
You think people of course would change,
they would pivot, but they don't.
They do more of the same. They doubled
down on what they've already done.
They try harder. Okay, so how
do you change what you're doing?
A good starting point is to take
a step in the opposite direction.
So if he's been spending a lot of money,
spend less,
if you've been making
a lot of phone calls,
make fewer phone calls or none at all.
So these new steps might not work either
in which case change and change. Again,
keep pivoting until you find something
that works and then do more of that.
My second quote is, if you experience
any negative emotion, doubt,
fear, frustration, anger,
it's almost always assign to redirect
your attention either to the task at hand
or do others.
Michael Jordan once said that he's
never thought about missing a shot.
And the reason he's never thought about
missing a shot is that it's attention is
totally focused on making the shot.
So it would be wrong to say that Michael
Jordan was self confident about making
the shot because the attention there
would be focused not on making the shot,
but on himself.
So self confidence in this sentence,
it's almost as bad as self doubt. Your
attention is focused on the wrong thing.
It's focused on yourself as opposed to
the shot you're trying to make or the
task at hand, whatever it might
be or the other, the other person.
So I've doesn't actually hundreds of
other quotes that resonate with how I live
in my life, but for a billboard I
would confine myself to those four.
What are bad recommendations that you
hear in your profession or area of
expertise?
My field is that of global finance and
virtually all investors had been told
when they were younger or implicitly
belief or tacitly encouraged to do so.
But I think cookie cutter curriculum's a
business schools, they all attend that.
The more they understand the world,
the better their investment results.
It makes sense,
doesn't it?
The more information we acquire
and evaluate the air quotes,
better informed we become
and the better our decisions.
Accumulating information becoming better
informed is certainly an advantage in
numerous, if not most fields, but not in
the counterintuitive world of investing.
We're accumulating information can
actually hurt your investment results.
So in 1974 Paul Slovic,
a worldclass psychologist and a pure
of Nobel laureate, Daniel Kahneman,
decided to evaluate the effect of
inflammation on decision making.
This study should be taught at every
business school in the country.
Slovak gathered eight professional course
handicappers and announced to them,
I want to see how well you predict
the winners of horse races. Now,
these handicappers were all seasoned
professionals who made their living solely
on their gambling skills,
so love it,
told them the test would consist of
predicting 40 horse races in four
consecutive rounds in the first round.
Each gambler would be given the five
pieces of information he wanted on each
horse, which would vary from
handicapper to handicapper,
one handicap or for example,
it might want the years of experience
the jockey has had as one of his top five
variables. While another might
not care at all about that,
but want the fastest speed for any given
a horse that achieved in the past year
or the weight of the jockey or whatever.
Finally,
in addition to asking the handicappers
to predict the winner of each race,
he asked each one to also state how
confident he was in his prediction.
Now, as it turns out, they were an
average of 10 horses in each race,
so we would expect by blind chance,
random guessing that each handicapper
would be right 10% of the time and that
their confidence with a blind guests
to be 10% so in round one let's see how
they did with just five pieces
of information. The handicappers,
we're 17% accurate,
which is pretty good,
actually 70% better than the 10% chance
they started with given zero pieces of
information.
And interestingly,
their confidence was 19% almost exactly
as confident as they should have been.
They were 17% accurate and 19%
confident in their predictions.
Excellent calibration.
In round two they were then
given 10 pieces of information
in round three 20 and
in the fourth and final
round each handicapper,
it was given 40 pieces of information.
That's a whole lot more statistics than
the five pieces of information they each
started with.
Surprisingly,
their accuracy had flat lined at 17%
there were no more accurate with the
additional 35 pieces of information
they had. Unfortunately,
their confidence in their predictions
had nearly doubled to 31% so the
additional information made them no more
accurate but a whole lot more confident,
which would have led them to increase
the size of their bets and lose money.
As a result,
beyond a certain amount of information,
a certain minimal amount,
additional information only
feeds confirmation bias.
Leaving aside the considerable cost
and delay occasioned and acquiring that
information,
the additional information we gained that
conflicts with our original assessment
or conclusion,
we conveniently ignore or dismiss
while the information that confirms our
original decision makes us increasingly
certain that our conclusion was correct.
So to return to investing.
The second problem with
trying to understand the world
is that is simply far too
complex to grasp and the more dog at
our attempts to understand the world,
the more earnestly we want
to explain that's air quotes,
explain events and trends in it.
The more we become attached
to our resulting beliefs,
which are almost always
more or less mistaken,
blinding us to the financial trends that
are actually unfolding right in front
of our eyes. Worse, we think
we understand the world,
giving us a false sense of confidence
when in fact we are almost always more or
less mistaken.
You hear all the time from even the most
seasoned investors and financial expert
that this trend or that
doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense for the dollar keeps
going lower or it makes no sense that
stock's keep going higher.
But what's really going on when investors
say that something makes no sense is
that they have a dozen or whatever reasons
why the trend should be moving in the
opposite direction. Yet it keeps
moving in the current direction.
So they believe the trend
air quotes makes no sense,
but what makes no sense is
their model of the world.
That's what doesn't make sense.
The world always make sense.
We just don't understand it.
In fact,
because financial trends involve human
behavior and human beliefs on a global
scale,
the most powerful trends won't make
sense until it becomes too late to profit
from them. By the time investors
formulate an understanding, again,
a false understanding that gives them
the feeling of confidence to invest.
The investment opportunity
has likely already past.
So when I hear sophisticated investors or
financial commentators say for example,
that it makes no sense how
energy stocks keep going lower.
I know that energy stocks have a lot lower
to go because all those investors are
on the wrong side of the trade in denial,
probably doubling down on their
original decision to buy energy stocks.
Eventually there'll be forced to throw
in the towel and have to sell those
energy stocks.
Driving prices still lower.
What is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made?
I've made many investments in my
life of money, of time, of energy,
of passion and emotion,
and one of the best payoff for the
amount invested was learning to meditate.
I've always been driven,
excited by the world,
so my mind is continually racing at a
thousand miles per hour pursuing this
question or that creating
this system or that nonstop,
24 hours a day,
365 days a year,
366 on leap years.
Now,
all that nonstop mental and psychic
stimulation gets exhausting of course,
and if you want to perform
optimally at anything,
you need to find a way to recover
from the stresses of that activity.
So I knew that though I should find a
way to turn off my mind and air quotes,
just relax, just enjoy, just be.
For years I had failed to find
a way. I tried everything. Yoga,
exercise.
I even tried hypnosis.
I researched once the best hypnotist in
New York City as a way to somehow turn
off my hyperactive mind,
but after four attempted and usually
expensive sessions with this guy,
the hypnotist gave up saying,
your mind is too active to submit to
the hypnosis will. Thanks a lot. Dark.
I told I'm not concealing my annoyance.
That's exactly why I had come to him.
Then about two years ago,
my bestie, Josh Waitzkin,
recognizing that I couldn't unwind or
disengage from my relentless analyzing the
world, especially in the financial world,
recommended that I take up meditation.
Sorry,
I said it doesn't work for me.
I can't sit still long enough for any
benefits of meditating to kick in.
So we asked, have you ever tried
heart rate variability training,
HRV training? And I said, no. What's that?
He said that you just focused on your
breathing using biofeedback to measure the
and the amplitude. Hence the word
variability of your heart rate.
The heart not surprisingly,
registers all our realtime
emotions and stresses.
So the normal heartbeat is highly erratic
staying within a tight band around an
average.
The goal with the VI biofeedback training
is to gain control over your own heart
rate by focusing on your breathing,
making your Jagat heart rates
smooth out like a sine curve,
and to widen its amplitude.
That sounded interesting,
but it wasn't until I reframed
meditation that I submitted a trying it.
The problem with meditation I thought
was that it wasn't practical and worse.
The time I spent meditating was time.
I could have spent analyzing the world,
but I eventually reframe meditation
as a way to relinquish control of my
conscious mind so that my more powerful
unconscious mind could take over and my
analysis of the world would improve
motivated by that reframing.
I enthusiastically adopted biofeedback
HRV training and in a few weeks learn to
quiet my mind after just a single
deep diaphragm belly breath,
getting the ability to achieve
a zen like calm on demand. Now,
whenever I need to detach from the world
or from the stresses of daily life and
to allow my mind arrest,
I simply get centered and inhale from my
diaphragm and I do so numerous times a
day, a minute here, a minute there,
and at least once a day I waste.
That's air quotes.
I waste a larger 15 to 20 minute
block of time meditating in this way,
but it's not waste of time.
Of course,
since the increased creativity and
productivity from these many restorative
sessions is far more valuable than
the time I spend being unproductive.
Again, air quotes. While meditating,
meditation is one of the most practical,
powerful productivity
enhancing tools ever created,
and learning to meditate is one of
the best investments I've ever made.
What purchase of $100 or less has most
positively impacted your life in the last
six months or in recent memory?
Well,
this purchase is not less than $100 but
159 it is too close to pass up the heart
math, inner balance, biofeedback,
monitor. It detects your hearts,
my nudist rhythms,
and send a graph to your smartphone
facilitating HRV training.
And while you're at it,
get the book heart math solution.
In the last five years,
what new belief, behavior,
or habit has most improved your life?
The understanding which has become a
habit that is most improved my life in the
last five years dramatically
so is recognizing the
importance of others and not
only changing the world, but in
enjoying it by nature. I'm an introvert.
So much so that some friends revealed
after high school that there were
students, classmates of mine
who had never seen me speak,
not once in all of high school.
By the time I graduated from Oxford,
after doing my undergraduate work at
the Wharton school at the University of
Pennsylvania, I had begun to emerge from
my interior world to a great extent,
but I was still 95 to five on
the introvert extrovert scale.
I very much enjoyed the company of other
people, but only for brief periods,
1530 minutes beyond which I'd reach
overload and I need to seclude myself to
recharge after college.
In my career,
my success in the world was the product
of my insights and imagination and
thinking.
So I inhabited the world of ideas far
more than I did the world of people.
The more and better ideas I came up with,
the more success I achieved.
So it came as a surprise,
relatively late in life. In fact,
only in the past year that if
you want to change the world,
you have to enroll others in your
plans and vision. Not only that,
but I discovered the immense pleasures
and satisfactions that can be derived
from focusing on others and putting them
first and the surprising discovery that
the more I gave to others,
which I'd always done,
the more the universe
gave me back in return.
Whereas in the past when I went
outside and encountered others,
I would invariably be lost in thought.
Now I am solely focused,
not inwardly and my ideas,
but outwardly and connecting with others.
I mentioned this discovery publicly for
the first time in a live group podcast I
did with Utm back in December,
2016 and was inspired shortly thereafter,
the right of book and invitation to
the great game, a parable of love,
magic and everyday miracles in which I
articulate my three guiding rules of life
first, whenever possible,
connect with others. Second,
with enthusiasm. Strive always to
create fun in the light for others.
And third,
lean into each moment and every
encounter expecting magic or miracles.
This discovery so profoundly
altered my life path,
revealing for the first time I true
mission on this planet then and now divide
my life into two periods,
prediscovery of others and post discovery.
Now I so eagerly look forward to leaving
my home each day wondering what magic
I'll create encountering others
that I can scarcely contain myself,
my days now have a natural rhythm between
introversion and extroversion that is
akin to breathing when I'm alone.
I inhale my ideas and
then I exhale with others.
The number of remarkable people in
serendipities and successes that have come
into my life since I've adopted
this awareness of others,
which quickly developed into a reflexive
habit of directing my attention solely
on them when I am not alone has been
nothing short of astonishing. So Tim,
I have to thank you for inspiring that
book with that question at the 92nd
street y,
what have you learned this year and a
the book and invitation with the great
game will be coming out soon in January.
What advice would you give to a smart
driven college student about to enter the
real world? Yikes. I could write a
book in response to this question.
So instead I'll just toss out
a hodgepodge of observations,
truths, Maxim's, caveats,
and exhortations that I wish I had known
or at least fully appreciated when I
just entered the real word myself.
Congratulations.
You recently left or you'll
soon be leaving an ecosystem.
You've known your whole life for an
entirely new one to switch analogies.
You're leaving a game you've played since
at least first grade with a rule book.
You've consciously,
if not unconsciously assimilated and
more or less mastered for an entirely new
game with no formal rule book handed out.
You'll have to write your own rule book.
You'd think the point of education would
be to prepare you for the real world,
but the real world is more unlike
school than like it. Indeed,
you'll find that many of the traits and
habits and behaviors that served you
well in school, well either not work in
the real world or will work against you,
so you'll have to adopt an experimental
attitude towards everything,
continually testing what works
for you and what doesn't.
Graduating from college or leaving
behind your formal schooling,
whatever form it took to enter the real
world is a major step since it marks the
first time in your life when you'll be
making most of the decisions that affect
that life rather than being told what
to do or being assigned what to do.
You won't receive a clear course
syllabus every few months detailing the
assignments and exactly what is expected
of you and the standards by which a
single person,
your professor will evaluate your work
and award you a single letter grade.
So I'll have to find your own incentives.
Another enormous difference is that for
the first time you won't be needing to
navigate simply a cohort of peers,
more or less exactly your age and
from very similar backgrounds if not
aspirations,
no longer now you'll be interacting with
a broad spectrum of humanity in all its
delightful but sometimes
challenging diversity.
So you'll need to acquire a whole new set
of people skills and ways to relate to
others and cultivate what's
known as emotional intelligence.
So the rhythms of your life from the
daily to the weekly to the monthly to the
yearly will be ones you established on
your own rather than the structures and
timetables dictated by the
academic calendar year.
You'll find this lack of structure
more or less disorienting,
and the more you develop routines
daily and weekly, at least the better.
Another recommendation,
instead of asking yourself air quotes,
what do you want to do? Ask
Rather, who do you want to be?
Whatever you're doing for work, whatever,
throw yourself into it wholeheartedly.
Even if you realize it's a transitional
gig while you search for something
better.
Don't ever worry that air quotes,
you'll be doing this for the
rest of your life you want,
but if that's your attitude,
you're missing out on the next point.
If there were a single
quality underappreciated by
recent graduates that will
most ensure your career success.
It's not the obvious ones
like intelligence and good
habits and discipline and
the capacity for hard work,
but rather this enthusiasm in all matters,
be enthusiastic and others
will want to be around you,
including work with you and you'll
flourish. Unrelenting enthusiasm.
I can't recommend that.
Strongly enough. Unrelenting.
As long as you're following
all the other rules here,
have patient's life moves at once much
slower than you expect and much faster.
You can be doing everything right,
paying your dues,
and for months or years it seems like
you're not making any progress and then
all of a sudden, boom, your life
explodes forward. At lightspeed,
Benjamin Disraeli said that the secret
to success was being ready for your
opportunity when it presents
itself. Until then, pay your dues.
Your success in the world rests largely
on your ability to create compelling,
positive visions of the future that
others feel irresistibly drawn to be.
A part of that goes not only
for your professional life,
but also for your personal and even
romantic life. As early as you can.
Try to connect to your personal mission.
Who are you here on this planet to be?
Mark Twain said,
the two most important days in your life
are the day you're born and the day you
discover why.
I promise you,
the sooner you become aware of a mission
larger than yourself that you are
devoted to the exponentially more.
Yeah,
more rapidly your personal and
professional goals will be achieved.
Find out what you love to do and do best
and cultivate that talent or talents.
Then be relentless and finding jobs or
situations in which those strengths and
passions are most in demand.
No what your hammer is in a sense,
and then look for nails to hit.
The most important gifts and goals
in life, including love, success,
and happiness are never achieved.
I want to underscore that never
achieved by pursuing them directly.
Those people focused on finding love,
for example,
have their attention and priorities
diverted from being the kind of loving,
lovable person that would actually
attract the love they're looking for.
And if your focus is on becoming
successful or wealthy or whatever,
your attention isn't focused on the
activities and tasks and others that will
actually lead to that success
and wealth. Love, success,
and happiness catch you best by surprise.
While your attention is focused on doing
in the world and being your best in
that world.
When you feel overwhelmed or unfocused,
what do you do?
When I'm feeling unfocused,
the first question I ask myself is,
am I rehearsing my best self?
And if the answer is no,
I ask myself how I can reset each
day presents us with 86,400 seconds,
which means each day presents
us with virtually countless
opportunities to reset,
recover our balance,
and continue rehearsing our best selves.
If I realize my focus is off and certainly
when I'm experiencing any negative
emotions, I asked myself, where
should my attention be right now?
Almost always the answer is my mission,
which is like a beacon
that always backends,
but sometimes I take on too
many commitments because
I sometimes have trouble
saying no to others,
eager to work with me.
I can become a bit over committed and
overwhelmed. So when that happens,
rather than attempting to do
everything badly, I ask myself,
what activity or commitment can I cut
out right now that will free up the most
time? Reminds me in a funny way of this
new story I read ages ago about a small
European town,
I won't say what country lest I offended
unnecessarily in which the postal
workers had trouble keeping
up with their deliveries.
So on Monday they do their
best to deliver the mail,
but they'd have some pieces
leftover, which they'd add
to Tuesdays delivery pile.
Tuesday they'd fall further
behind of course, and
Wednesday and Thursday for the,
still by Friday they'd have an
enormous pile of undelivered mail,
which they burn.
So they could start fresh on Monday.
The process where we'd repeat the next
week, a small bonfire every Friday,
purging their delivery vans of
that week's undelivered mail.
Now that was a highly dubious
way of resetting each week,
which I don't recommend,
but the idea of having a fresh restart
whenever overwhelmed is excellent.
So let's say by noon on any given day
I'm falling behind and it's clear I'm in
danger of becoming overwhelmed in short
order rather than attempting to keep all
of my afternoon appointments,
which I'd reach later in later in the,
as the day progressed,
I scan my calender and I asked myself,
which is the earliest
appointment as it were,
I can burn by postponing
it to another day.
I'd rather reschedule one appointment
and make the other three on time.
Then be late and frazzled for all
four appointments that afternoon.
Speaking of which each week I leave
one day completely open and schedule a
pretend trip out of the city so that
I'm not tempted to fill it in any way,
not even meeting with friends
or having other fund diversions.
Then if an emergency arises or I
fall behind and become overwhelmed,
I know I have a free day air quotes,
a free day to use anyway. I'd like.
So when I get overwhelmed trying to
juggle too many balls simultaneously,
I ask myself,
which one or two balls can I sit for the
moment so that I can get caught up on
all the others in the last five years?
What have you become better at saying
no to? This is such an important lesson.
Being able to say no,
it's especially hard for me because of
my inherent optimism and my unflagging
enthusiasm and because they always leaned
into each moment in every encounter
expecting magic or miracles and because
life has rewarded me increasingly with
tantalizing offers.
So I not infrequently say yes too
often to my regret because I wind up
overloading my cognitive or physical or
energy bandwidths are simply run out of
time.
So I found a powerfully useful editing
principle as it were in deciding whether
to say yes or no to any particular
request or proposal or invitation where
opportunity is answering.
The following question will saying
yes to this option in advance.
Any important goals in my life,
especially in my calling or my mission.
The key point there is to have
a personal mission in the world,
which will not only give you a stronger
sense of direction and structure and
energy and motivation personally
as well as professionally,
but it's also a filter with which you
can decide whether to say yes to any
particular short term or long term options
or opportunities that arise for you
on any given day.
Keep in mind that the time
spent on pursuits and not
related to your mission is
time that could have been spent on it.
Not that all your time of course
should be devoted to your mission.
You'll have other goals in your life,
personal and professional,
and sometimes you'll just want to goof
off or otherwise enjoying yourself,
but the sooner you
connect to your mission,
the sooner all aspects of your
life will fall into place.
What is an unusual habit or an absurd
thing that you love and the old television
show? Candid camera reprise
by Ashton Kutcher, punk.
In more recent times,
unsuspecting people were videotaped,
coping in realtime with an
insane prearranged situation.
Usually to great and suing hilarity.
I get endless little light,
covertly ambushing unsuspecting
strangers with random acts of kindness.
So for example,
after ordering my ice Latte,
I'll give a Starbucks Barista a $20 bill
and tell him or her to calm the person
right after the person behind
me for whatever he or she wants.
And to give that person
that change as well.
I don't do the person immediately behind
me who might suspect that I was the
mystery benefactor.
Then I set my latte from afar and watch
the confusion give way to smiles when
the random beneficiary
realizes the unexpected bounty,
sometimes the person leaves
all the changes that tip.
Sometimes he or she will pay it forward
and gift the next person behind a free
coffee,
but the beneficiary always leaves smiling
broadly and I know that I've unleashed
a positive ripple effect in that person's
community and to anyone he or she
encounters that day.
I love spreading the magic.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll
get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
99 designs. Whether you need a logo,
custom website, APP, book
cover or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process
as easy as possible.
I've used 99 designs for years now I've
used the book covers some mock ups for
the four hour body which went on to become
a number one year at times bestseller
illustrations of all different types
for the multivolume, the Tao of Seneca,
which you can check out and other graphic
design projects for a long time now
and I've been very impressed with
the quality of their designers and
illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it.
You should check out some of my
projects@ninetyninedesignsdotcomforwardslashtimireallyencourageyoutotakealookbecauseyouwillbeimpressedwithninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash ten nine nine designs
has freelance experts and more than 90
design categories in their platform
lets you work directly with one designer
that you choose.
If you like their stuff,
which is what I did
for the town of Seneca,
or you can get concepts from multiple
designers and then pick your favorite.
So whether you're starting a business
or just looking for extra design, help,
resources,
etc. 99 designs has a solution right now,
you guys,
my listeners can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first design.
To check out your first free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page. You can also find their
samples of projects from you guys,
listeners who've used 99
designs for logos, apps,
even product packaging.
So check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash tip.